We're almost there. Things are coming together very nicely.
The only thing we're missing is set anchors.
We have to somehow take a row and the row number within the board
and figure out where all the anchors are and what the values of those anchors are.
To find the anchors we can do that within the row.
An anchor is something that's next to an existing letter.
That will get most of the anchors but not quite all of them,
because notice if we didn't have this row here, we wouldn’t know that that spot is an anchor.
To find all the anchors, we're going to have to look at all the rows
or at least the two adjacent rows on either side.
To find what the anchors are in terms of the set--can anything go there as in this anchor,
as in this anchor, any letter can appear there, or is it a restricted set like this one.
That we're also going to have to know--what are the other cross words?
Here, if there's only a U there and nothing down below--
this is the edge of the board or there is empty stuff down below--
then this anchor can only be the letters that fit in there to make a word going in this direction.
Let's dive right into defining set anchors.
This is different than most of the functions written so far in that it actually mutates the row
rather than returning a result.
We start in the normal way. We're going to iterate over the row--the good parts of the row.
Then what I'm going to do is take the i-j position on the board
and find all the neighbors for that board--
that is all the squares in the in the north, south, east, and west location.
Then I'm going to say what are the anchors?
Well, if the square is the star, the starting square, then that's an anchor by definition.
Otherwise, if the square is empty and any of the neighbors is a letter, then that's an anchor.
Now, I've arranged that neighbors(board) is a function that returns the neighbors in this order--
north, south, east, and west--and now I'm saying we're operating on a row,
if the neighbor to the north or the south is a letter,
then we have a cross word that we have to deal with.
If not, then it's an unrestricted anchor.
What do I want to do if I have these crosswords?
I want to find the crossword on the board. What does that mean?
In this location right here, which would be row 2 and column 2,
I want to say that the word on the board is an empty square followed by a U.
If I go into the interpreter, I want to be able to have this interaction where here is my board.
Now if I find crosswords within that board from position 2, 2--that's that position right there
right after the A and above the U--what I want to say is that there is a word,
and the word is a dot followed by a U--there it is.
If we fill in that anchor, we're going to have a word, which is a dot followed by a U.
Where does the word start? Well, it starts in position 2.
It could have started someplace else.
If we had a big board, there might have been a word that started all the way up here and went down.
For example, we're not actually going to call findcrossword on positions that aren't anchors,
but if we did, it would still work.
If we find cross words from position 1, 2--that's the where the A is--
what's the cross word that intersects through that A? Well, that's JAG.
It begins in row number 1.
Now we're up here, we found the cross words,
we found the row that the cross word begins in, we found what the word is,
and now we're saying we're going to fill in this location. It's going to be an anchor.
It's anchor where the letters are all the letters with which we can replace the dot in dot U
and make something which is a word.
We can go back to our interpreter and test that out.
We can say if W is the dot U, then what is this anchor of all the letters
where W replaced by a letter is in WORDS.
That's the anchor with X, M, and N as possibilities.
Now we're going to say insert that anchor into row[ i ].
Insert into this spot to the right of the A above the U the anchor
that says an X, an M, or an N can occur right in that location.
That's setting the anchor if there are cross letters above or below.
Otherwise, we have an unrestricted anchor.
For example, this anchor here to the left of the D--any letter can go in there.
We've already defined the global variable any to be the anchor that allows any letter to occur.